There's so much to say and so little time
do they want to talk
about the general will,
who his most important
contribution to political science.
And I will also want to talk about
the legacies of Rousseau in what he,
uh,
what he's meant for the world,
that he,
he,
he did so much to shape.
Okay.
But I want to start first
with the general will,
which is his answer to the problems of
civilization or the political problem.
Uh,
of the second discourse that
we talked about last week,
the problems of inequality,
the problem of Mr Pro,
the problem of our general discontent
social contract is his answer to
the problem of natural freedom.
Uh,
this is so in a way
because for Russo nature,
he tells us,
provides no standards or guidelines
for determining who should rule.
Okay.
Unlike Aristotle,
man is notch here,
a political animal.
And notice that when Russo speaks of
the social contract in the general will,
is the foundation of all
legitimate authority.
He means literally that all standards of
justice and right have their origins in
the will in this unique human
property of the will or free agency.
It is this liberation of the will from
all transcendent sources or standards,
whether those be found in nature,
in custom,
in revelation,
in any other source.
Uh,
the,
the liberation of the will
from all of these sources.
That is the true is at
war center of gravity,
of Rousseau's philosophy.
It is a world that begins to emphasize
the primacy and the priority of the will.
A moral point of view that I want to
indicate a little later finds it's a,
in many ways it's a very powerful
expression and the philosophy of a manual
Kant,
but given Russo's,
let's call it libertarian
conception of human nature.
Uh,
his description of the actual mechanism
of this social contract may come as
something of a surprise to us.
The problem to which the formula of the
general will is the answer is stated
succinctly.
Rousseau in book one,
chapter six of the social contract,
find a form of association.
He writes,
which defends in,
protects with all the common force.
The person and goods of each associates
and by means of which each one,
while uniting with all obeys only himself
and remains as free as before this,
he calls the fundamental problem for
which the social contract is the solution.
That statement famous statement book one,
Chapter Six really contains two parts
that that merit close attention.
The first part says
for me,
Oh,
okay.
I thought it was,
I thought it was for me.
The first part of that clause,
uh,
so is that the aim of the contract is
to protect and defend with the common
force,
the goods and person of each member.
Uh,
so far think of that this is entirely
consistent with locks claim or even Hobbs
is claim that society that the purpose
of society is to protect the security or
the life,
liberty and estate of each of its members
and get Rousseau adds to this Lockian
or liberal clause.
Uh,
you might say a second,
uh,
and more distinctly Russolo sewing claim,
namely that the contract must ensure
not only the conditions for mutual
protection and the preservation
of law of self and property,
but rather awesome or also the,
in uniting with one another.
He says each person obeys
only himself and then he says,
remains as free as they were before.
But how is this possible?
We want to know,
uh,
isn't the essence of this social
contract that we give up some part of our
natural freedom,
uh,
to guarantee mutual peace and security.
How can we,
how can we remain as
free as we were before?
Uh,
and his,
he says,
obey only out I hit the,
that the participant obey only himself.
That is the paradox in many ways.
Or the fundamental problem is he calls
it to which his contract is a solution
and Rousseau provides
an answer as follows.
He says,
properly understood.
These clauses are all reducible to one.
Namely,
he says,
the total alienation of each associate
together with all of his rights to the
entire community,
the total alienation of each associates
with all of his rights to the entire
community.
And those two phrases,
total alienation and entire community,
uh,
are obviously central here,
in the first place or persons must give
themselves entirely over to the social
contract to,
to ensure that the terms of the
agreement are equal for all.
The total alienation clause,
uh,
as it were,
is Russo's manner of ensuring that the
terms of the contract are the same for
everyone.
But secondly,
when we alienate ourselves,
it is crucial.
He says that this be done or given to
the entire community for only then he
wants to argue is the individual beholden
not to any private will or any private
association or to some other person,
but to the general will the
will of the entire community.
The social contract is the
foundation of the general will,
which is for Roussel the
only legitimate sovereign,
not kings,
not parliaments,
not representative assemblies,
not presidents,
but the general will of the entire
community is the only general sovereign,
the doctrine of the famous doctrine
of what we call the sovereignty of the
people or popular sovereignty.
Yeah.
Since everyone combines
to make up this will,
uh,
when we give ourselves
over to it entirely,
he wants to argue,
we do nothing more than obey ourselves.
The sovereign,
in other words is not some distinct third
party that is created by the contract,
but rather the sovereign is simply
the people as a whole acting in its
collective capacity.
The people in their collective capacity.
Okay.
No,
you might suggest that there
is something deeply amiss here.
That is to say from a highly
individualistic set of
premises where each person
is concerned only in the state of
nature or in the pre contract tradition,
only with the protection of their lives,
persons and property.
Rousseau seems to be leading us to a
highly regimented and collectivized a
conclusion where the individual has given
over virtually his or her entire being
to the will of the community.
In what way does this render
us as free as we were before?
In what way do we remain a
free and obey only ourselves?
That seems to be a the problem.
Does this,
does Russo's formula for the general will
of recipe or a formula for freedom or
is it a recipe for the tyranny of the
majority of the type later analyzed by
Tocqueville that we'll be seeing,
uh,
after,
after the break,
Russo wants to say,
paradoxically only this total alienation.
Do we remain free?
Why is this,
why,
why is this?
Because he wants to argue.
No one is dependent upon
the will of another.
The people established through
their act a new kind of sovereign.
The general will,
which he says is not strictly
speaking the sum total,
the additive total,
uh,
of the individual wills
or the individual parts,
but is more like the general interest
or the rational will if you want to use
that kind of content formulation.
The rational will have a community.
Since we all contribute to the
shaping of this general will.
When we obey its laws,
we do.
He wants to say no more
than obey ourselves.
And Russo describes this new kind of
freedom that we achieve under the general
will.
Uh,
he wants to say that this brings about
in some ways a radical transformation of
human nature in itself.
The freedom of the citizen under the
general will is not the freedom of the
state of nature.
It's not the freedom to do anything we
like anything that our will and power
allows us to do.
But it is a new kind of freedom
that he calls moral freedom,
a freedom to do what the law commands,
the passage from the state of nature.
He writes to the civil state.
The passage from this state of nature
to the civil state produces a remarkable
change in man for its substitutes,
justice for instinct in his behavior and
gives his actions a moral quality that
they previously lacked.
And Roussel continues
that statement as follows.
What man loses through the social
contract is his natural liberty and an
unmitigated right to
everything that tempts him.
And he can acquire what he gains his
civil liberty and proprietary ownership of
all he possesses.
But,
and here I think is the crucial
argument or the crucial clause,
but he writes to the
proceeding acquisitions.
That is to say civil liberty,
uh,
could be added the
acquisition of moral liberty,
which alone he says makes man truly the
master of himself for to be driven by
appetite alone is slavery and obedience
to the law one has prescribed for
oneself is freedom.
That has a remarkable statement.
Obedience to the law that one
prescribes for oneself is freedom.
That is moral liberty,
which is only created and possible
through the social contract.
And the implications of this,
the moral and political
implications of that statement,
uh,
are
need is here in many ways.
Reus where Roussel
departs most powerfully,
most dramatically from his
early modern predecessors.
Consider the following,
uh,
for Hobbes and Locke.
Liberty meant,
uh,
that sphere of human conduct,
which is unregulated by the law.
Remember Chapter 21 of Leviathan we're
Hobbes says where the law is silent
preacher,
mid hid in his term
where the law is silent,
the citizen is free to do
whatever he or she chooses to do.
Freedom begins so to speak
where the law is silent.
But for Rousseau law
is the very beginning,
uh,
of our freedom where the law is silent.
We may have a kind of natural freedom,
but our moral freedom,
uh,
we are free to the extent that we are
participants in the laws that we in turn
obey.
Freedom means acting in
conformity with self imposed law,
a radically different understanding
of what freedom consists and it seems
underlying that difference between one
could say Hobbes and Locke on the one
side and Russo on the other is a
difference between two very different
conceptions of liberty.
One might call them
liberal and Republican.
Uh,
respectively.
Small r Republican of course
democratic even if you like for liberals.
Uh,
following in the tradition
of Hobbes and Locke,
again,
freedom has always meant a sphere of
privacy with the law does not intrude or
where other people do not intrude.
This,
this is why the separation of the public
and the private sphere has always been
so sacred to liberals because
only in the private sphere,
only in that area of civil society,
uh,
where the state does not intrude is
the individual really and truly free.
But for the Republican theory of liberty,
of which you so is the most powerful,
uh,
modern,
exponent.
This separation of pro public and private
is only an exercise in what might be
thought of his private selfishness.
The task is rather to create a community
where the individual in the public
interest are not in conflict with
one another with the individual,
does not think of him or herself as
a being a part from the social body.
This is the freedom of the citizen for
Russo who takes an active role in the
determination of the laws
of one's own community.
Uh,
Russo's purpose in saying
this and then writing,
this seems to be to bring back to life
a concept that he believes has been
dormant,
had laid dormant for centuries,
and that concept is the citizen.
The last people who really
knew what a citizen meant.
He says,
we're the Romans in an a
footnote again to book one,
Chapter Six,
he indicates what?
That the how to what degree the true
meaning of citizen has been lost on modern
subjects.
Most modern men,
he writes,
mistake a town for a city and
a bourgeois for a citizen.
Think of that most mistake
of bourgeois for a citizen.
The modern world furnishes almost
no examples of what a citizen is.
And this is why it is necessary for
Russo to return to the histories of
antiquity,
especially Rome and Sparta,
to find models of citizenship
only in these societies has,
can one find the spirit of self sacrifice
and devotion to the common good,
a kind of patriotic devotion upon
which citizen ship is founded.
If I could take perhaps Russo's most
memorable example of the true citizen,
it comes from an example,
he lifts from the Roman Ryder Plutarch,
uh,
that he uses in the
opening pages of his book,
the meal,
which I hope you will have a
chance to read at some other time.
And here he tells an unforgettable
story for anybody who ever reads a meal.
A Spartan woman,
he writes,
had five sons in the army and
was awaiting news of the battle.
It five sons in the army and
A helot slave arrives trembling.
She asks him for news,
you're five sons were killed.
The hell at replies based slave.
Did I ask you this?
We won the victory.
He says,
the mother runs to the temple
and gives thanks to the gods
here for Russo is the ancient citizen
an example that is both terrible and
sublime,
which of course he wants it to be,
intends it to be.
There is the example of
what the true citizen is.
The question when you consider this
possibility is weather Russo's idea of the
freedom of the citizen freedom to live
under self imposed law leads to a higher
form of nobility,
high higher than the kind of low minded
pursuit of one self interest as Roussel
wants.
He wants to dignify politics again by
leading to a higher form of nobility,
or does it result in a
new kind of despotism,
the despotism of law,
the despotism of obedience to
the general will and of course,
underlying that sinister
a reading of Rousseau's,
uh,
of Russo is the famous or maybe infamous
statement that not only that the
general will is the source of freedom,
but that anyone who obeys,
who refuses to obey the general will,
may be in his famous formulation,
may be forced to be free.
That anyone who disobeys it,
uh,
in being chastised or being,
can be as you were forced to be free,
uh,
recall that this is a
conception of freedom,
which again,
is almost the opposite of that,
of what we might call
the liberal tradition.
A view,
which in a,
in a,
in a gigantic,
slightly paradoxical way,
was given a very powerful
formula formulation by hubs.
I want to read a passage that I read
a couple of weeks ago from Hobbs,
which I think stands as a striking
contrast to dat of Rousseau's.
Uh,
in chapter again in chapter
21 of Leviathan Hobbs Rights,
the Athenians and the Romans were free.
That is they were free Commonweal's.
Not that any particular men had liberty
to resist their own representatives,
but their representatives had the
liberty to resist or invade other people.
Hobbes clearly says that the ancient
freedom was the freedom of the cult of the
collective.
It wasn't the freedom of the individual,
the freedom of the authorities as he says,
to resist or invade other people.
There is written and the tourists of the
city of Luca remember that in the great
characters at this day,
the word Libertas,
and yet he goes on to say,
no man convince,
infer that a particular man has more
liberty or immunity from service to the
Commonwealth there than in Constantinople.
That is to say freedom for
hubs consists of as he puts it,
immunity from service,
immunity from service.
And for this reason,
there is no reason to believe that anyone
is free or in the Republican city have
Luca,
which has Libertas on the wall.
Then in Constantinople that seems to
already a hundred or so years before
Rousseau suggests a powerful
alternative to their view.
His view of freedom to Hobbs is
point like Rousseau's is extreme.
Uh,
and that in many ways is the
power of these two views.
Uh,
Hobbes is view as freedom
is immunity from service.
Uh,
Russo's view is that freedom consists,
you might say only in service.
Our freedom starts where,
where the law begins.
And again,
at the basis of this or radically
different views of the role of participant
political participation
in lawmaking for Russo.
Again,
laws are legitimate only if everyone
has a direct share in making them.
It doesn't mean we all
agree with the outcome,
but only if we have a some kind of share
or voice in making them for hubs for
lock,
for the authors of the federalist papers.
On the other hand,
the direct involvement of the citizen in
lawmaking is clearly a subordinate or a
secondary good legislation is better
handled by persons chosen from the
electorate who are so to speak,
the agents or representatives
of the people.
This was what the federalist authors
argued was the great advance of modern
political science,
the doctrine of representation.
What is far more important
for the federalist authors
as well as for lock hubs
and that tradition is that law is be
generally known that they be applied by
impartial judges rather than they be the
direct expression of the general will.
Uh,
in many ways underlying the,
again,
liberal conception of law is a certain
distrust of the collective wisdom or the
collective sovereignty of the people.
Uh,
it is too cumbersome in many ways and
also too dangerous a mechanism to call
people together to decide on
matters over public concern.
This is better left
according to this tradition,
to representatives.
Russo obviously could not disagree more.
Okay.
One could say that Rousseau makes who
ROIC and unreasonable assumptions about
human nature.
Why do we want to gather
together constantly or often
to decide to deliberate
and to debate over
questions of public concern?
Most people,
it's hard enough just to
get most people as we know,
to go out to vote.
Why do we want to engage
in endless debate?
Uh,
something like,
you know,
uh,
college,
council,
uh,
meeting,
trying to discuss,
uh,
what to do,
whether to buy or not a new set
of dumbbells for the weightroom.
You know,
this is a debate that will go
on for hours and hours and May,
maybe even weeks.
Don't people simply want to be left alone.
Why do you,
uh,
why,
it Russo's again,
he seems in some way to make
a unreasonable assumptions
about human nature and
our capacity to,
uh,
to d to engage in debate.
But Russo will tell you he is
not being idealistic at all.
He is starting from the
assumption of men as they are.
He says,
unless everyone who wants to say is
engaged in the process of legislation,
there is no way for you to know that the
laws will be an expression of your will
rather than simply the private
will or corporate will have some,
uh,
individual or intermediary body.
You will find yourself in a condition of
dependence and slavery and the will of
others.
And what is really an issue,
uh,
for Russo is a freedom from
dependence on some faction,
some interest or some association
that we have come to call today.
Interest groups in some way.
Russo's appeal is not to our altruism,
uh,
but rather to our selfishness
in some way our desire,
our private or selfish desire
to preserve our freedom and,
and resist the willful
domination of others,
uh,
upon it.
So,
um,
so far this all in many ways is very
abstract and Roussel deliberately sets out
his,
uh,
plan for the general
will in the lane in a,
in a highly abstract and
semi semi technical language.
But he turns to questions,
particularly in books three about how
is the general will actually applied.
How does it,
uh,
how does it,
how is it applied?
And here,
Rousseau is far more specific,
uh,
sociologically and so on about the
conditions under which the general will,
uh,
or a general will,
can come about in the first place.
The general will can only
operate in small states,
much like the size of an
ancient republic in one place.
When particularly notable
place in the social contract,
he says only the island country of
Corsica is today a place where the general
will might be established.
The modern nation state,
uh,
as we have come to think
of it as far to diff,
large and diffuse a to determine
the general will such a,
such a state touch.
Large states will necessarily,
uh,
entailed considerable
degrees of social inequality,
of wealth,
of status.
And with such inequality,
such inequalities,
there can be no general will.
And finally,
or in addition,
uh,
as such a state where the general will
is operative would be one that would have
to in some sense is shoe,
uh,
that temptations of commerce and luxury,
for these bring with them.
Uh,
again,
uh,
large scale,
inequalities.
His ideal city seems to be a
kind of agrarian democracy,
a small scale,
a agrarian society.
Uh,
and yet at the same time we
might get the impression that,
uh,
only a direct democracy,
would satisfy Russo's requirement's
for a general the general will.
And yet we find out this
is not quite the case.
Uh,
in book three which I helped
you will look at with some care,
uh,
he shows surprising flexibility,
about the forms of government that may
be appropriate to different physical,
uh,
and geogrid in different climates
and different topographies and so on.
In the chapter on democracy,
he remarks even where
there a people of God's,
it would govern itself democratically
and then he adds so perfect.
A government is not suited to men.
So he is skeptical about the
possibility of a direct democracy.
And by that he means a democracy.
Not only were the people legislate,
bring,
create law,
but where they are in charge also with
the administration of law as well,
the execution or enforcement of the law,
he is very skeptical about
that kind of democracies.
Again,
democracies are only possible under very,
very special,
unique circumstances.
Otherwise,
aristocracy monarchy,
some kind of even mixed government,
uh,
is possible or even desirable.
He insists and the separation of powers
for much the same reasons that one finds
in lock,
the people who make the law should not
be charged with responsible for executing
and enforcing them.
And throughout this part of the book,
Russo seems to be in dialogue with an
unnamed rival when he'd sometimes simply
refers to as a famous author.
That author is of course Montesquieu.
The,
the,
the author of the spirit of the law is,
uh,
that came out in 1755.
And Montesquieu was of course,
famous for arguing at different forms
of government must be tailored to
different climates,
different geographies,
different circumstances in many ways.
In book three,
Russo seems to indicate or to introduce,
uh,
a very,
very,
almost unroof civilian,
uh,
emphasis and prudence,
moderation,
flexibility,
uh,
that that seems at odds with the dogmatic
claims of the first two books with its
emphasis upon the absolute
inviolability of sovereignty.
But most important for Roussel,
it is important that legislative authority
in whatever kind of constitution and
under whatever kind of government,
that legislative authority is only
is always held by the people in their
collective capacity.
This is why in a very powerful chapter,
book three Chapter 15 Rousseau
rejects all together the legitimacy of
representative government.
That passage or that chapter
could be taken already,
is a kind of repudiation,
not just of lock,
Locke's theory of the representative,
but also,
you know,
20 years or so before the fact of the
federalist argument for representation
sovereignty,
he says,
can never be delegated to sovereignty,
can never be,
uh,
represented.
It can only be expressed.
The general will can never
be delegated to some,
to someone else.
If you do that,
if you delegate the
Authority for making law,
you are,
he wants to say on the first step down
the road to tyranny because you give
someone else some partial
body or association,
the power to make law over you.
Oh,
the law making function can only
legitimately be jailed by the people
themselves.
Uh,
I'm going to skip over a bunch of stuff
that has to do very interestingly.
I hope you can discuss
it in your sections,
perhaps with Rousseau's
account of the legislator,
the extraordinary individual who was
responsible at the beginnings of regimes
for shaping the general,
for molding a people and for as it were,
giving the general will a kind of
shape and distinctive direction.
And I'm also going to skip,
uh,
for our purposes the very interesting
and discussion of civil theology,
which occupies the theme,
the very last chapter of the book book
for Chapter Eight where Russo talks about
the way in which,
uh,
a civil religion must be tailored to,
bring about love and
obedience to the general will.
Uh,
it was that chapter,
I should say,
that more than anything else led to,
uh,
the books being burned,
and band,
uh,
in Geneva and in other places and for
its powerful attack on Christianity in
that,
in that chapter,
uh,
I'm going to pass over that
with the time being,
to look at the legacies of
Rousseau and to talk about what,
and I just deliberately use
that word in the plural,
the legacies of Roussel because there
is virtually no part of modern life,
uh,
political,
cultural,
intellectual,
moral,
uh,
with that does not in some sense bear
the stamp or fingerprints of Jacques
Rousseau Russo's description of the
legislator as a kind of political founder,
uh,
creating,
creating a people was for many,
uh,
in many ways.
Uh,
the,
uh,
closely,
closely connected with
the French revolution and
particularly the claim of the
revolutionaries to create a new nation,
a new people,
a new,
a new sovereign,
a new popular sovereign and France.
Consider the following words of
the famous revolutionary rubs.
Pierre in his homage are Russo,
a written in 1791 divine man.
This is Rob's PR divine man.
You taught my s you,
you,
you taught me to know myself
while I was still young.
You made me appreciate the dignity of
my nature and reflect upon the great
principles of the social order.
The old edifice is crumbling.
The Portico of the new edifice
is rising up upon its ruins.
And thanks to you,
I have brought my stone to it,
received my homage.
As weak as it is,
it must please you.
I wish to follow your venerable footsteps.
Happy if in the perilous career that an
unprecedented revolution just opened up
before us,
I remained constantly faithful to the
inspirations that I found in your text.
It can be no.
People might tell you that the writings
of Rousseau had no influence on the
French revolution that
the French revolution was
brought about by bread crises
and economic problems.
And so on.
Absolute Baloney.
Uh,
the,
the writings of Rousseau,
uh,
had this powerful influence on the
idea of creating a new people and a new
nation.
And yet,
despite a,
what appears to be a utopian and
impractical and his politics,
again,
Russo had a profound influence
on the politics of his era.
He was approached during his lifetime,
uh,
to write constitutions for Poland and,
and for Corsica.
And of course,
that was the island
where a generation later,
a man named Napoleon Bonaparte,
uh,
was,
born who attempted to,
you might say in a,
in some way extend route sows
teaching not just a France,
but to all of Europe,
uh,
at the point of a gun to bring democracy
to all of Europe at the point of a gun.
Does that sound familiar at all in any
way related to events going on now?
Uh,
we're,
we have a new kind of
Bonaparte has perhaps,
um,
in many ways,
although Russo's attack on representative
government would seem to put him
strongly at odds with the
American constitution,
uh,
his glorification of the rural
republic based on equality,
moral simplicity,
skepticism of commerce and luxury.
This was to be re echoed in
the writings of Jefferson,
uh,
with his ideal of a nation
of small yeoman farmers.
And certainly any reader of Tocqueville's
d depiction in celebration of the
independent townships of New England,
uh,
Tocqueville's account of this
was directly dependent on,
uh,
his reading of Rousseau,
the small scale experiment
in direct democracy.
That Tocqueville saw was a real world
example of a kind of politics governed by
the general will.
And when you read those early chapters
from Tocqueville's democracy in America
about the New England township,
you will very much see
Tocqueville looking at America,
do the lenses that were in
some ways crafted or shaped by,
uh,
Rousseau.
Uh,
and that influence was palpable
on a whole host of later,
uh,
19th century writers,
like toss die.
Uh,
for instance,
who celebration of
Russian peasant life was,
uh,
inspired by Rousseau in to Tolstoy,
Rousseau influenced,
uh,
the establishment of the year Israeli
kibbutz movement that was also founded by
Russian Jews who had
been influenced by toll.
So you have a sort of
self reinforcing cycle,
uh,
have influenced these,
you might say small rural socialistic
experiments and communal living,
uh,
exhibit the same kind of equality,
self-government devotion to the common
good that Roussel helped people imagine.
Might be possible.
And yet Russo's influence
was not limited to politics.
If he was a divine man,
as Robespierre called him,
he was no less so to Emmanuel Kant
who claimed that it was his reading of
Rousseau,
uh,
that led him to learn respect for
the dignity and the rights of man.
Uh,
that's what roots,
that's what concept he called Russo,
the Newton of the moral universe.
Uh,
Kahn's entire philosophy.
And I hope you also have
a chance to read cons,
critique of practical reason in
some later philosophy course.
Concent.
Tire moral philosophy is a kind of
deepened in radicalized Roussel organism
where what Russo called the general will
is transmuted into what Kant calls the
rational will and the
categorical imperative.
And it was not the least of Rousseau's
a legacies that after his death,
he became a hero both to,
to,
to the revolution,
uh,
and to the counterrevolution both to a
revival of Roman style republicanism as
well as to romanticism.
Or if I couldn't use the
words of a great Russo,
Ian,
a Jane Austin,
he became both an advocate
of sense and sensibility.
Uh,
Emerson Thoreau,
uh,
American transcendentalism
with its worship of nature
and it's protests against
the kind of deadening and
corrupting influence of society.
All of these people were the
direct areas of Rousseau,
Rousseau,
his last work,
uh,
a book called the reveries of a solitary
walker set the stage for later American
classics like Walden Pond
and generations of nature.
Writers that have come after it and
imitated it only by turning away from the
noise and buisiness of society can one
return to what proceeds society to the
feeling of existence,
to the feeling of or sweetness a of
mere existence to the sentiment of
existence.
The something is swatch as Russo
caused at the sentiment of the self,
there is a kind of union that
he celebrates with nature
that puts the solitary,
this Tyler Terry Walker,
uh,
either above humanity or below it.
That type of man,
a four shadowed by Rousseau.
The solitary is no longer a philosopher
in any sense that we would understand
it,
but might be better understood
as an artist or a visionary.
Uh,
he can claim a privileged place in society
because such a person regards him or
herself as the conscience of that society.
His claim to privilege is based
on a heightened moral sensitivity,
uh,
read it in his wisdom or is,
rationality.
And it is this kind of
radical individualism,
the radical detachment of the solitary
from the interests of society,
uh,
that is perhaps Russo's deepest
and most enduring legacy,
uh,
for,
for us today.
So on that note,
I wish you a good break.
Uh,
I hope you have a lot of Turkey to eight,
and you come back well rested.
And most,
most,
most importantly,
we come back with a win over
the evil empire to our north.
Thank you very much.